antoine bonjour alors le président russe
1 vient de s'exprimer en visioconférence
à l'occasion du g20 qu'est ce qu'on peut
retenir de son intervention mme ebadi
poutine a commencé en mentionnant
rapidement les mesures adoptées par les
autorités russes pour faire face à cette
pandémie des mesures salutaires bien sûr
mais aussi économique citant le chômage
massif et de longue durée comme facteur
principal d'une augmentation de la
pauvreté
il a ensuite inscrit cette crise
sanitaire que nous traversons en ce
moment dans un contexte historique
estimant qu'il s'agit d'une des pires
crises que le monde ait connues depuis
près de 100 ans et coûté l'ampleur des
problèmes auxquels le man et a été
confronté en 2020 est absolument sans
précédent
l'épidémie de corne à berru c'est le
confinement généralisée et le gel de
d'une partie de l'activité de l'activité
économique a suscité des transformations
majeures et des problèmes que l'économie
mondiale n'avait jamais connu depuis la
grande dépression
ensuite quasiment qualifiés l'économie
américaine de locomotive en disant qu'il
ne pourrait y avoir une reprise durable
sans le rétablissement de l'économie des
états unis
enfin de la meilleure poutine a évoqué
les pistes de sortie de crise avec en
premier lieu bien sûr évidemment les
vaccins contre le coc u19 et les vaccins
russe en particulier à ce titre il
souhaite tout comme antonio gouttes il
reste que ces vaccins soient accessibles
au plus grand nombre écouter notre pays
la russie est tout à fait prête à
participer à ces travaux d'élaboration
de vaccins notamment notre vaccin
spoutnik v qui a été le premier à être
mis sur le marché dans le monde et c'est
pareil à nouveau subir ce qui a été mis
au point un deuxième vaccin 3e et sur le
plein point d'être validé actuellement
donc nous avons mis toutes les
ressources possibles ici parce que notre
objectif commun
et d'assurer pour l'ensemble de la
population de la terre une protection
sûre et fiable pour conclure vadimir
poutine a noté les initiatives du g20
pour relancer l'économie et a rappelé
toute l'importance compte à ses yeux les
grandes institutions internationales des
institutions comme le g20 donc ou encore
les nations unies et c'est de cette
façon en m'améliorant encore davantage
les mécanismes de coopération
internationale que pourront je cite être
relever les défis qui se présentent
aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup aux douanes pour toutes
ces précisions antoine clair aux nôtres
correspondre à moscou